.
Man hat täglich
mit Jugendlichen zu tun,
die auf dem Weg sind.
Sie zu unterstützen und ihnen zu
helfen, den richtigen Weg zu finden,
ist meiner Meinung nach etwas
vom Grossartigsten, das möglich ist.
* Dynamische Musik: "Don't you
(Forget About Me)" von Simple Minds *
Gibt es jemanden,
den du sehr bewunderst?
Ja, es gibt einige Personen,
einer davon ist mein Lehrer.
Er ist seit 30 Jahren Lehrer
und hat immer noch den Elan,
Schüler zu unterrichten.
Es ist unglaublich,
was er schon alles geleistet hat.
Hallo, Joe. Wie geht's?
Hallo.
- Hallo!
Hoi, Inês.
- Hallo.
Wie geht's euch?
- (Alle) Gut.
Und du?
- Sehr gut.
Herzlich willkommen.
- (Alle) Vielen Dank.
Acht Jahre ist es her.
- Unglaublich.
Aber ihr seht noch genau gleich aus.
- Ja, Sie auch!
Ja, wirklich.
- Also gut.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Rhythmischer Chorgesang *
* Jubel, Applaus *
Endlich fertig!
Das war das Adventskonzert 2013.
Vielen Dank euch allen, dass ihr
mir ermöglicht, euer Lehrer zu sein.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Sekundarschullehrer Joe Hediger
ist seit Kurzem pensioniert.
Drei seiner ehemaligen Schüler/-innen
schauen mit ihm acht Jahre zurück.
Damals filmten sie ihren Alltag
im letzten Schuljahr in der Sek A.
Die Schüler waren immer gleich alt:
13, 14, 15. Ich wurde immer älter.
Bei euch war ich schon 56,
als ihr bei mir begonnen habt.
Du hast es dann bis ins Rentenalter
weitergezogen?- Ja.
Noch ein Jahr länger.
- Sogar?
Sie baten mich fast auf Knien.
Ich hätte sonst
in der zweiten Sek aufgehört.
Sie fragten mich, ob ich
das dritte Jahr noch machen könnte.
Und mir gefiel es, ich hatte
Energie, was sollte ich sonst tun.
Ich blieb noch ein Jahr.
Joe Hediger war es wichtig,
seine Klassen mit seiner Heimat,
der Innerschweiz, bekanntzumachen.
Besonders, weil die Schüler/-innen
ganz andere kulturelle Wurzeln
mitbrachten.
In unserer Klasse sind 26 Schüler
und 21 verschiedene Sprachen.
Zum Beispiel?
- Oh.- Albanisch!
Albanisch.
Dominikanische Republik.
- Und du?
Jamaica.
Kroatien.
- Brasilien.
Kosovo. - Türkei.
- Portugal.
Albanien.
- Portugal!
Italien?- Ja.
- Kosovo.
Du bist aus dem Kosovo?
- Ja.
Schweiz und Deutschland.
Portugal.
Der einzige wirkliche Schweizer
bin wohl ich.
30 Jahre Schuldienst im Kanton Schwyz
waren für Joe Hediger genug.
Mit Mitte 50 entschied er sich,
nach Zürich zu wechseln,
wo die Klassen ganz anders aussahen
als in seinem Heimatkanton.
Das hatte ich hier im Schulhaus
in Schwyz: 100 % Schweizer.
100 % aus Schwyz.
Einfach von hier.
- Ja.
War das anders, auch
wegen des Klimas?- Völlig anders.
Wenn ich fragte:
"What's your favourite food?"
Rösti.
Alle sagten dasselbe.
Wenn ich das bei euch fragte,
kamen verschiedenste Menüs,
einfach der kulturelle Hintergrund
und das Essen davon,
das spielt da hinein.
Ich suchte etwas Neues.
Ich schaute mir
verschiedene Schulen an.
Bei dieser Schule
gefiel mir das Leitbild.
Und ich sah, dass die Schule
sehr multikulturell ist.
Das faszinierte mich.
- Die meisten schreckt das ab.
Nein, das ist das Beste, absolut
genial, ich will nichts anderes.
Warum?
Diese Kinder bringen so viel mit.
Und sie bringen so viel Vielfalt
in eine Klasse -
nur schon wegen
des kulturellen Hintergrunds,
der Kultur von zu Hause.
Das ist faszinierend, und
sie gehen ganz anders miteinander um
als eine homogene Klasse
nur mit Schweizern.
Alle, die sagen,
das funktioniere nicht,
sollen mal bei uns vorbeikommen -
das funktioniert.
Ihr wart
meine allererste Klasse in Zürich.
(Alle) Ja.
Woher kommen denn deine Eltern?
- Meine Mutter ist aus Kolumbien.
Mein Vater ist Schweizer,
meine Mutter hat keine Probleme.
Aber trotzdem ... Nicht wegen
der Karriere, sondern menschlich:
Man ist etwas anders.
Ich bin Benjamin Vogt.
Ich bin 15 Jahre alt
und in der dritten Sek.
Das ist meine Mutter.
Und ähm ...
Ich habe sie sehr lieb.
Anfang Sommer habe ich mich geoutet.
Eigentlich nahmen es alle gut auf.
Meine Eltern haben nichts dagegen,
meine Familie auch nicht.
Meine Freunde unterstützen mich.
Was ist?
- Ich will mich verabschieden.
Schönes Wochenende!
Oh mein Gott! Okay.
Aus dem Filmmaterial
des letzten Schuljahres
entstand 2014
eine 13-teilige Youtube-Miniserie
über die multikulturelle Klasse
und ihren Lehrer.
(Aufnahme) I hope you're
all ready for next weeks ...
Eine Mission von Joe Hediger:
Den Schülerinnen und Schülern
gutes Englisch beizubringen.
(Aufnahme) If you ask me:
Turning that book into a film ...
Ich bin sehr froh,
du hast Wert auf Englisch gelegt.
Ich studiere jetzt Englisch.
- Was?- Ja.
Im Ernst?
- Ja, wirklich.
Hey!
- Ja, vielen Dank!
Ziel erreicht.
Du hast mich für
die englische Sprache begeistert.
V.a. hast du es
aus freien Stücken getan.
Hut ab und vielen Dank dafür.
- Danke.
Was habt ihr bei mir gemacht?
PET oder First?- Beides.
Ich bin immer noch dankbar
für dieses Zertifikat, heute noch.
Ich auch, das half mir sehr weiter.
Eu sou Inês, 15 anos,
eu venho de Portugal.
Ich bin Inês, 15 Jahre alt
und komme von Portugal.
Zu Hause spreche ich
Deutsch und Portugiesisch.
Jetzt sind wir
im Zimmer meines Bruders.
Er heisst Alexander.
Ich nenne ihn Alex.
Als er klein war, passte ich jeweils
auf ihn auf, schon ziemlich früh.
Meine Eltern gingen zur Arbeit
und ich blieb mit ihm zu Hause.
Dadurch wurde ich
auch schnell erwachsener,
weil ich die Verantwortung
für meinen Bruder trug.
Inês filmte damals
viele Facetten von sich selbst
und offenbarte so einen sehr
persönlichen Einblick in ihr Leben.
Ich habe meiner Freundin
heute eine Rose geschenkt.
Heute ist unser Einjähriges.
Das ist kein Pflaster.
Keine Ahnung, was es ist.
WC-Papier?
- Nein.
Was ist das?
- Soll ich's dir erklären?
Ich habe das schon sehr lange.
Und es bedeutet etwas,
es ist Thai-Silber.
Für mich ist das ein Dankeschön
an dich für dieses Jahr.
Danke!
- Bitte.
* Sie lachen. *
Ja, also ...
Was soll ich dazu sagen?
Pubertät halt.
Nein, ich nahm meine Aufgabe wahr.
Ich öffnete mich vor der Kamera,
ich war mich selbst.
Gewisse Dinge würde ich heute
nicht mehr machen vor der Kamera.
Ich liess die Menschen
sehr nahe an mich heran.
Aber in diesem Alter -
ist es okay.
Es ist okay, mal traurig zu sein,
mal ein Drama zu haben.
Das gehört dazu.
Es war wirklich unser Leben.
- Ja.
Und du hast es wirklich gezeigt.
- Das stimmt.
Du hast mich einige Male erstaunt.
- Wirklich?- Ja.
Ich glaube, das generierte
ein negatives Bild von mir.
Überhaupt nicht, im Gegenteil,
du kamst aus dir heraus.
In der Klasse warst du
eher zurückhaltend und ruhig.
Was sagten deine Eltern zum Film?
Sie liessen mich einfach machen.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie sehr ich auch sie gefilmt habe.
Also.
Heute ist der letzte Abend,
bevor wir nach San Diego gehen.
Ich bin sehr nervös.
Oh, jetzt kommt meine Mutter.
Und, ähm ...
Mein Vater machte heute
extra Carbonara für mich.
Ich bin einfach ...
- (Entfernt) Meret!
Ich muss essen gehen.
Das ist meine Katze, sie hat Angst.
Tschau, Büsi.
Joe Hediger flog mit seinen Klassen
jeweils für drei Wochen
nach San Diego,
damit sie ihr Englisch
praktisch anwenden konnten.
Für die Schüler/-innen
die maximale Aufregung.
Ich beginne gleich zu weinen.
(Frau) Wo trefft ihr euch?
- (Meret) Ich weiss es nicht!
Ich fand es einfach extrem cool.
Ich wollte, dass die ganze Welt
sieht, wie ich gerade lebe.
Guten Morgen.
- Grüezi.
Wo warst du denn?
Ich bin jetzt da, sagen wir's so.
Die meisten von ihnen
waren noch nie im Ausland ohne Eltern
und für viele der damals 15-Jährigen
war es der erste Flug
ihres Lebens überhaupt.
* Emotionale Musik *
Tschüss!
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl,
dass man Schülern in diesem Alter
noch etwas beibringen kann,
sie sind noch offen.
Ich weiss, wie ich war im Gymnasium.
Man ist abgehoben und denkt:
"Was der da vorne erzählt,
weiss ich doch alles schon."
Das war mein Eindruck.
Aber vielleicht ist es heute anders,
bei mir ist das 50 Jahre her.
Die meisten
seiner Abschlussklasse von 2014
haben eine Lehre gemacht
und studieren jetzt.
Einige wollten sich
nicht mehr vor der Kamera zeigen.
Beni, Inês und Meret gewähren uns
nochmals einen Einblick in ihr Leben.
Andere schickten
ein filmisches Update, z.B. Oliver:
Um euch zu zeigen,
was ich in der Freizeit so mache.
Da ist dann noch Denis.
Hallo zusammen, hier bin ich wieder.
Nach der Sekundarschule machte ich
die kaufmännische Lehre bei Login.
Bis im letzten Jahr
war ich bei der Airline Swiss.
Dort konnte ich
zwei Jahre weiterarbeiten
und machte auch
die Berufsmaturität.
Nachher ging ich zum Militär.
Im Moment studiere ich International
Management an der ZHAW.
Ich bin im ersten Jahr
im zweiten Semester.
Ab September werde ich
für ein Jahr in Madrid studieren.
Darum ist meine
aktuelle Wohnungslage so,
dass ich immer noch
im Hotel Mama wohne - zu Hause.
Es ist ein Vollzeitstudium,
aber ich arbeite nebenbei,
da ich die Möglichkeit habe,
in einem Teilzeitpensum
bei einer Versicherung zu arbeiten.
So kann ich mir dieses Auslandjahr
überhaupt finanzieren.
Meret, sag etwas über mich.
- Über dich?- Ja.
Manchmal würden wir gerne
unsere Körper tauschen.- Nein.
* Ein Mädchen lacht. *
Fail.
In der ersten Sekundarstufe
war ich in ihn verliebt. - Ich auch.
Hast du dich angemeldet? - Ich habe
mich noch nicht angemeldet.
Ich habe Mittwoch und Donnerstag
Schule, aber ich möchte es machen.
Er ist geduldig.
Findest du?
Ich bin seit fünf Jahren
in einer Beziehung
mit meiner wundervollen Freundin.
Genau.
Ich bin immer noch sehr glücklich.
Es wurde niemand von der
Sekundarschule meine Freundin.
Es wollte mich niemand haben,
nein, nein.
Ich fahre nicht mehr Mofa.
Ich fahre auch nicht Motorrad.
Ich schaffe es
gerade noch mit dem Fahrrad.
Das bringe ich gerade noch fertig.
Ist gerade Ramadan?
Bist du am Fasten?
Was würde ich
dem 15-jährigen Oliver sagen?
Ich würde ihm sagen:
"Wie du es machst,
wird's schon gut sein."
"Mach dir nicht
zu viele Gedanken über Dinge."
"Es gibt immer wieder
Hochs und Tiefs,
aber solange man seinen Weg geht,
wird es am Ende schon gut kommen."
Ich bin Joe Hediger.
Ich bin Sekundarlehrer
und bin verheiratet.
Ich habe drei Kinder
aus meiner ersten Ehe
und noch zwei Töchter
aus meiner zweiten Ehe.
Sie sind aber alle erwachsen.
Joe Hediger hat vor acht Jahren, wie
seine Schülerinnen und Schüler auch,
Privates von sich gefilmt.
Es ist ein Privileg, wenn man
an so einem schönen Ort wohnen kann,
an den man jeden Abend
nach Hause kommen
und sich von den Alltagssorgen
erholen kann.
Darum geht es mir so gut und darum
bin ich meistens so aufgestellt.
Stefanie hat davon profitiert -
nicht nur als Schülerin
im Englischunterricht,
auch sonst lernte sie
vieles und einiges fürs Leben.
... sunscreen because it's sunny.
And I wanna sleep here in this bed.
Oh.
Good night, bye.
Hallo zusammen.
Mein Name ist Stefanie
und ich war 2014 bei Herrn Hediger
in der Abschlussklasse.
Ich begann dann eine Lehre.
Auf diese freute ich mich
unglaublich stark.
Ich durfte in einem Reisebüro
die kaufmännische Lehre machen.
Diese Branche
faszinierte mich schon immer.
Zum ersten Mal
eigenes Geld zu verdienen,
war richtig cool, ja.
Deshalb ging fast
eine Art Traum in Erfüllung.
Leider verwandelte sich dieser
nach einem Jahr in einen Albtraum.
Ich machte die Lehre
bei der SBB und diese beschloss,
alle Reisebüros zu schliessen.
Im ersten Moment
überforderte mich diese Situation.
Now you're going home.
- Yeah, we do.
Mit 16 stand ich dann
einfach ohne Lehrstelle da.
Ja.
Es war schwierig,
muss ich ehrlicherweise sagen.
Ich fand aber einen
neuen tollen Lehrplatz bei TUI.
Dort konnte ich meine Lehre
abschliessen und es war alles super.
Ich erlitt aber
einen weiteren Schockmoment:
Ich fiel aus der BMS.
Darum musste ich nach der Lehre
noch die BMS nachholen.
Im Anschluss
machte ich sogar noch die KME,
die Maturitätsschule für Erwachsene,
weil ich
so grosse Lust aufs Lernen hatte.
Heute studiere ich
an der Universität Zürich Jura,
und es gefällt mir extrem gut,
ich bin sehr happy.
Ich habe zwar immer noch einen
Nebenjob im kaufmännischen Bereich,
aber hauptberuflich
bin ich Studentin.
Seit zweieinhalb Jahren
bin ich in einer festen Beziehung.
Ich wohne aber nicht mit
meinem Freund, sondern in einer WG.
Meinem 15-jährigen Ich
würde ich mit auf den Weg geben,
dass man im Leben
nicht so viel planen sollte.
Schlussendlich wird sowieso
alles komplett anders kommen.
Man kann nichts dagegen tun,
da man gewisse Dinge
einfach nicht beeinflussen kann.
We are here at the station.
Herr Hediger
war immer ein Vorbild.
Er inspirierte uns immer dazu,
uns nicht mit dem
Selbstverständlichen zu begnügen,
sondern mehr zu wollen.
So, seid bitte alle ruhig.
Die Meinung jedes Einzelnen
zählte in Joes Klasse.
Das hiess:
Alle mussten sich einbringen.
Jetzt möchte ich kurz Feedback.
Was habt ihr heute gelernt?
Sonst geht alles wieder weg. Ja?
Und Lehrer Hediger förderte
Kreativität und Selbstverantwortung
in hohem Masse:
Auf der einen Seite
kommen die modernen Lieder,
und auf der anderen Seite kommen die
Weihnachtslieder - Teil 1, Teil 2.
Die Vorder- und Rückseite müssen
gestaltet werden, da man es faltet.
Aber ihr habt genügend Fantasie,
damit das problemlos geht.
Macht ein paar Vorschläge
und zeigt sie uns.
Wir stimmen dann darüber ab,
ob sie okay sind.
Ich möchte,
dass die Klasse dahintersteht
und nicht nur die Wenigen,
die das gestalten.
Bringt Vorschläge.
Am meisten blieben mir
auch die Gespräche,
die wir
ausserhalb der Stunde führten.
Das hat mir sehr gefallen.
Das war mir ein grosses Anliegen,
dass ich
nicht nur der Fachvermittler bin,
der Fachidiot.
Mir war wichtig, dass ihr
auch noch andere Dinge mitbekamt.
Diese Gespräche schätzte ich sehr.
- Mhm.
Ich kann mich erinnern, dass wir
jeweils Diskussionsrunden machten,
bei denen wir uns
in zwei Gruppen aufteilen
und verschiedene Meinungen vertreten
mussten.- Pro und Kontra.- Genau.
Ich denke, es ist sehr schlimm, wenn
sich eine Lehrperson nicht kümmert.
Ja.
Dass wir in der Französischstunde
manchmal Englisch sprachen ...
In der BMS hatte ich vor jeder
Französischstunde Bauchschmerzen.
Das ging mir auch so.
Wegen der Coronapandemie
hatte ich keine Maturprüfungen
und ich war so froh.
Ah, du gehörst zu diesem Jahrgang.
- Ja, Glück gehabt.
Vielleicht wäre mir die Französisch-
prüfung noch in die Quere gekommen.
Ja?
Beni ist einer der wenigen,
der direkt nach der Sekundarschule
ins Gymnasium wechselte.
Der Beginn seines Englisch-
und Spanischstudiums in Basel
vor zwei Jahren war für ihn
das Ankommen im Erwachsenenleben,
sagt er.
Früher hatte ich
grosse Körperkomplexe.
Ich fand meinen Körper
nicht so liebenswert,
wenn man das so sagen kann.
Das änderte sich mit der Zeit,
v.a. seit ich Mitte 20 bin
und seit ich
nicht mehr zu Hause wohne.
Denn jetzt bin ich self made.
Ich habe es aus eigenem Antrieb
bis hierhin geschafft.
Bereits das verändert deine Meinung
zu dem, was du im Spiegel siehst.
Um zu sparen,
lebt Beni wie viele in seinem Alter
in einer Wohngemeinschaft.
Seine Mitbewohner/-innen
sind ein paar Jahre älter.
Er hat von ihnen
schon einiges gelernt.
Wir können noch machen,
wenn es zu wenig hat.
Wieso ich kochen kann?
- Wegen mir.- Auch wegen ihr.
* Sie lacht. *
V.a. vegan kochen.
Wegen ihr
kann ich vegane Gerichte kochen.
Dank dieser WG und Michelle
esse ich v.a. auch gesund.
Ich komme aus einem Haushalt ...
Ich will jetzt nicht schlecht
über meinen Vater reden,
aber er hat sich mehrheitlich
sehr schweizerisch ernährt,
und ich dann auch.
Irgendwann wurde ich dicker
und fühlte mich nicht gesund.
Seit ich hier wohne,
fühle und ernähre ich mich gesünder.
Ich will mich
auch gesünder ernähren,
weil es Spass macht
und auch sehr lecker sein kann.
Foodtime, yes!
I'm so hungry.
Die Umgangssprache ist Englisch,
da immer jemand in der WG wohnt,
der oder die kein Deutsch spricht
Yeah, thank you,
I tried my very best.
Und sie pflegen
eine intensive Diskussionskultur.
Wir sind immer
an Politik interessiert,
aber es hat immer noch zu viele
alte Menschen in der Politik,
um die es
letztlich gar nicht mehr geht.
Wenn z.B. eine 70-jährige Person
noch eine politische Aktion
starten will, denke ich ...
Bist du denn aktiv in der Politik?
- Ich gehe wählen.
Ich bin kein politischer Mensch,
aber ich diskutiere gerne
über politische Themen.
Wir alle.
We all like to talk about politics.
Was sagst du zur Aussage,
dass ihr höchst unverbindlich seid?
Da ist etwas dran.
* Alle lachen. *
Aber, to be fair: Ich bin Millennial
und würde es auch von mir behaupten.
Wir tun uns einfach keine
abusive work environments mehr an,
wie das vielleicht
vorherige Generationen taten.
Leute der Boomer-Generation haben
vielleicht eher die Mentalität:
"Mach es einfach.
Live through the pain."
"Versuche dein Bestes."
Dann sind sie aber überrascht,
wenn jemand aus einer anderen
Generation nicht zufrieden ist.
Ich denke, sie waren
einfach von Beginn an unzufrieden.
Jetzt wollen sie uns vorwerfen,
dass wir unzufrieden sind.
Dabei begannen sie einfach,
es zu akzeptieren.
Wir hingegen hinterfragen es
und akzeptieren es nicht.
Wir sind die Generation,
die es langsam hinterfragt.
Am Anfang dachte man, man müsse
weniger arbeiten dank des Internets.
Wir merken jetzt:
"Fuck, wir müssen eigentlich noch
mehr machen wegen diesem Scheiss."
Ja voll.- Und es ist
alles sinnlos und dauert ewig.
Ich denke,
das darf man auch hinterfragen.
Immer am letzten Freitag im Monat
fährt Beni mit seiner WG
an der sog. Critical Mass mit,
einer weltweiten Bewegung,
die mit Fahrten durch die Innenstädte
auf den Langsamverkehr
aufmerksam machen will.
Es ist nicht nur
für die Fahrradpolitik,
sondern
für die linke Politik generell.
Man lernt beim Radfahren
auch Leute kennen.
Man schenkt sich
eine Zigarette beim Fahren.
Es ist einfach ...
* Schnelle Rave-Musik *
Und Alex?
- Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung.
Nein.
- Er war schon immer zurückhaltend.
Ich weiss auch nicht,
was für eine Lehre er machte.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen,
dass er Karriere macht.
In Mathe war er sehr gut.- Ja, wir
kopierten immer seine Hausaufgaben.
Ich bin Alex,
ich lebe zu Hause bei meinen Eltern.
Ich bin ein Einzelkind
und habe ein Katze namens Strolchi.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Ach, Strolchi.
Katzen sind schon schön.
Dieser Baum, den man hier sieht,
ist ein Kirschbaum.
Mein Vater hat ihn
nach meiner Geburt gepflanzt,
und er steht immer noch.
Ich muss ihn etwas heran zoomen.
Hoi, Papi.
Ich bin zufrieden
mit meinem Zeugnis.
Es war nicht das beste, aber ich
konnte es meinen Eltern zeigen,
und sie sind doch stolz auf mich.
Super, ich bin stolz auf dich, Alex.
Das hast du gut gemacht.
Andere waren schlechter.
Das tut mir natürlich leid für sie,
denn sie sind alle nett.
Z.T. sind sie aber selbst schuld,
wenn sie nicht lernen.
Ich begann eine KV-Lehre
bei E-Profil bei Mondelez,
einem internationalen
Lebensmittelhersteller.
Dann machte ich die Berufsmaturität.
Diese machte ich in einem Jahr,
also nicht berufsbegleitend.
Dann holte ich
die Maturität für Erwachsene nach.
Das zweite Jahr war speziell,
da ich im zweiten Halbjahr nur noch
von zu Hause aus Unterricht hatte
wegen der Coronapandemie.
Dann ging ich zum Militär.
Im September letzten Jahres
begann ich mein Studium
an der Universität St. Gallen.
Ich bin momentan single
und lebe allein in St. Gallen
in einer Zweizimmerwohnung.
Am Wochenende
fahre ich jeweils nach Zürich,
mein Lebensmittelpunkt
befindet sich nach wie vor dort.
Joe Hediger gab sich grosse Mühe,
dass wir gegenüber anderen Schülern
des gleichen Jahrgangs
einen Vorteil hatten.
Bei der Lehrstellensuche
half mir extrem,
dass ich bereits das
Cambridge-First-Zertifikat hatte.
Auch als Mensch hat er mich geprägt.
Es kommt selten vor, dass jemand
so Freude an seinem Beruf hat -
und das
auch noch nach so langer Zeit.
Das inspirierte mich,
selbst etwas zu finden,
das mich
auf ähnlich Art und Weise erfüllt.
Auch Carmen profitierte von der
hohen Sozialkompetenz in Joes Klasse.
Nach der Sekundarschule
begann ich eine Lehre als Kauffrau
in einem Geschäftsreisebüro.
Leider gefiel mir das nicht so.
Ich wollte sie auch abbrechen, tat
das zum Glück dann aber doch nicht.
Ich holte auch
die Berufsmaturität nach
und fand meine Berufung:
Ich arbeite als Sachbearbeiterin
auf dem Sozialamt der Stadt Zürich.
Im September beginne ich,
soziale Arbeit zu studieren.
Ich wohne immer noch zu Hause
zusammen
mit meiner Mutter und meinem Hund.
Mein Freund
zog letztes Jahr noch zu uns,
und jetzt sind wir eine Dreier-WG:
meine Mutter, mein Freund und ich.
(Beide) See you.
Meinem 15-jährigen Ich
würde ich sagen:
"Chill dein Leben. Nimm es locker.
Go with the flow."
Denn es kommt sowieso
alles anders als geplant.
"Plane nichts, sondern lasse es
auf dich zukommen. Sei happy."
Ich denke gerne zurück
an alle tollen Dinge,
die wir
mit Herrn Hediger unternahmen,
und an alles,
was er uns ermöglichte.
Z.B. der Besuch
beim Singing Christmas Tree
und alle Opernbesuche.
Wir sind jetzt
unterwegs in die Tonhalle,
um ein Cellokonzert
von Antonin Dvořák zu hören.
Grüezi.
- Hoi.
Freuen Sie sich auf heute Abend?
- Ja, sehr, das wird ganz toll.
Was wird gespielt?
- Die "5. Sinfonie" von Dvořák.
Und nach der Pause
gibt es das Cellokonzert h-Moll.
Sich dem Anlass
entsprechend zu kleiden
war Pflicht bei Lehrer Hediger.
Luisa.
Hoi.
* Schwermütige Melodie *
Ich möchte übrigens auch Lehrer
werden, aber nicht Sekundarlehrer,
sondern Gymnasiallehrer.
- Du auch?- Was, du auch, wirklich?
Wenn es gut kommt, beginne ich im
September als Unterstufenlehrerin.
So, an den Tisch.
Let me take a selfie.
* Sie singt auf Portugiesisch. *
Agora, para a mesa.
* Niesen *
- Gesundheit.
Ist ja gut.
Ist ja gut, wein doch.
Lass es einfach gut sein!
* Die Mutter spricht portugiesisch. *
Akzeptiere es doch einfach!
Du warst auch einmal so jung wie ich
und hattest deine Probleme.
Meine Grossmutter
weiss auch nicht alles.
Alles.- Nein.
- Doch, alles.- Ja, ist gut.
Acht Jahre später ist die Familie
für Inês immer noch sehr wichtig.
Nachdem sie einige Jahre
mit ihrem Freund eine Wohnung teilte,
ist sie nach der Trennung
wieder zu Hause eingezogen.
Ihren Lebensunterhalt verdient sie
noch immer im ehemaligen Lehrbetrieb
als Kundenberaterin.
Saúde.
Nach einer KV-Lehre mit Berufsmatura
studierte Inês
ein Semester Betriebswirtschaft,
war damit aber nicht glücklich.
Sie schaffte eben die Aufnahmeprüf-
ung an der Pädagogischen Hochschule
und hofft,
dass sie Lehrerin werden kann.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass ich studieren würde, niemals.
Auch wenn ich das Studium
vielleicht nicht schaffen werde,
macht es mich stolz,
dass ich es so weit geschafft habe.
Wir kommen gerade von der Kirche,
wo ich nicht filmen durfte.
Jetzt sind alle meine Gäste hier
und bedienen sich.
Das ist der Hauptgrund,
zusammen mit dem Geburtstag,
wieso wir heute Abend
alle hier versammelt sind.
Kevins Familie ist auch eingeladen.
So erhalten sie einen Einblick
in meine Familie und sehen,
wie wir feiern.
In unserer Kultur wird
anders gefeiert als in der Schweiz.
* Dynamischer Popsong:
"Danza kuduro" von Don Omar *
# Al bailar descontrola tus caderas.
# Y ese fuego que quema por dentro
y lento, te convierte en fiera.
# La mano arriba, cintura sola,
# da media vuelta y sacude duro.
Ich liebe es, zu tanzen.
Ich tanzte eine Zeit lang Hip-Hop,
aber das ist nicht so mein Ding.
Ich tanze lieber lateinische Tänze.
Die Freude am Tanzen ist geblieben.
Heute sind es die Majoretten Zürich,
für die sie sich ins Zeug legt.
Ja, wie immer.
Es ist immer dieselbe Position.
* Mitreissende Musik *
* Sie lachen. *
Was gibt es dir,
dass du das machen kannst?- Freude.
Das Zusammensein
und der Austausch mit den Mädels,
und die Auftritte sind sehr cool.
Die hatten wir während der Corona-
pandemie natürlich nicht so oft,
was natürlich sehr schade ist.
Aber wir freuen uns immer,
und wir planen immer wieder
eine Weihnachtsshow
mit all unseren Tänzen.
Das ist unser Ziel
und das motiviert uns.
Konzerte, Bühne, Auftreten -
für Joe Hediger
gleichwertig wie ein Schulfach.
Das zweite Stück,
das wir für Sie spielen,
ist "All I Want for Christmas
Is You" von Mariah Carey.
Es singt aber nicht Mariah Carey,
sondern Malik.
# All I want for Christmas ...
# ... is ...
* Jubel *
# ... you.
(Alle) # I just want you
here tonight.
# Holding on to me so tight.
# What more can I do?
# All I want for Christmas is you.
Ein grosser Applaus für
unsere Jungs und Mädchen
vom Käferholz und Joe Hediger!
* Jubel, Applaus *
Ich muss zugeben, früher
wollte ich immer Pilot werden.
Wirklich?
- Das war mein Traumberuf.
Das sagten Sie ein paar Mal.
Irgendwann schwenkte ich
auf Lehrer um.
Und das habe ich nie bereut.
Ich war 40 Jahre lang
Lehrer mit Leib und Seele.
Das hat man gemerkt.
Natürlich gab es Schüler,
mit denen ich nicht auskam,
die mich nicht mochten.
Das wirst du auch einmal erleben.
Am ersten Schultag kommen
die Schüler zum ersten Mal rein.
Und dann hat es solche
mit einem Ohrfeigengesicht.
Ich habe eher vor den Eltern Angst.
- Da denkt man: "Oh, nein."
Man muss da genau gleich offen sein,
aber es ist einfach so.
Auch der tollste Lehrer
muss sich manchmal
mit hormongeplagten Teenies und
anspruchsvollen Eltern herumschlagen.
Joe Hediger
holte sich die Kraft in der Stille.
Wir sind in Einsiedeln.
Ich komme ab und zu hierher.
Ich gehe zur Schwarzen Madonna,
wenn es mir nicht so gut geht
oder wenn ich etwas loswerden muss.
Ich bin zwar
kein sehr religiöser Mensch,
aber ab und zu
tut mir das einfach gut.
Momentan habe ich
ziemliche Schwierigkeiten
mit den Eltern eines Schülers.
Der Schüler trägt
nie die Schuld an etwas,
er kann tun, was er will.
Er hat ...
Letzte Woche
hat er in der Schule etwas zerstört.
Selbstverständlich
trägt nicht er die Schuld,
sondern wir Lehrer
verstehen ihn nicht.
Seine Eltern schieben
relativ viel auf uns Lehrpersonen.
Das bin ich mich zwar gewohnt,
aber trotzdem ...
Und meistens mache ich noch
einen Spaziergang im Klosterhof,
dort, wo sie die Pferde züchten.
Das finde ich einfach einmalig.
Die ganze Energie,
die ich hier in Einsiedeln tanke,
auf diesen Spaziergängen,
aber eben auch in der Kirche,
kommt mir später zugute: Ich habe
viel mehr Energie in der Schule.
Und ich kann auch
mit jenen Situationen,
die gar nicht so einfach sind,
besser umgehen.
Hier ist der Gesprächspartner,
nicht dort.
Ich wollte fragen,
welches Thema sie haben.- Also.
Wir machen eine Radiowoche ...
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Hey, hey, stopp, stopp, stopp!
Was haben wir hier?
Wir haben Kommunikationsregeln.
Wir kommunizieren
nicht so in dieser Klasse.
Wenn du etwas zu sagen hast,
äusserst du dich.
Dann gibt er dir eine Antwort
und wir warten.
Nulltoleranz
bei Rassismus oder Diskriminierung,
das ist Joes
oberstes Gebot im Klassenzimmer.
Ich muss sagen: Du hattest un-
glaubliches Glück in dieser Klasse.
Das hätte auch
in die Hosen gehen können.- Ja.
Wenn ich daran denke,
was in anderen Klassen abgeht,
wenn gewisse nur denken,
einer könnte schwul sein.
Was da abgeht an negativen Dingen.
Und bei dir -
du warst für alle einfach Beni.
Letztlich wurde ich
nie darauf reduziert.
Das muss ich ganz klar sagen.
In der Schule hat mich
nie jemand gemobbt.
Ich fühlte mich nie so, als
dürfte ich nicht ich selbst sein.
Hallo zusammen.
Also, wir sind hier in Winterthur.
Ich lasse mir die Haare schneiden.
Diese Jacke fand ich
im Keller meines Vaters.
Niemand weiss, wie sie dort hinkam.
Aber sie gehört jetzt mir,
schon seit ich 14 Jahre alt bin.
Ich habe sie mit Schnur repariert,
es fällt aber fast auseinander.
Kaufst du dir nicht oft neue Sachen?
Solange sie halten, halten sie.
Dieses T-Shirt trage ich
schon seit ich 13 oder 14 bin.
Hey, ciao!
- Hallo.
Lange nicht mehr gesehen.
- Ja.
Wie geht's?
- Komm rein.- Danke.
Nice.
Danke schön.
- Gerne.
Oh, mein Gott.
Vokuhila macht man
momentan ziemlich oft.
Da spricht nichts dagegen.
Willst du
das Iro-mässige beibehalten?
Ja, voll,
dass sie hinten lange sind,
vielleicht sogar noch etwas länger.
Wenn es Scheisse aussieht,
kann es immer noch weg.
Ich bin seit zwei Monaten
in einer Beziehung mit einem Mann.
Er ist 18 Jahre alt.
Und er absolviert eine Lehre.
Ich bin happy.
Er half mir auch, mein Leben
zu ordnen und alles zu regeln.
Ich bin nicht mehr
der extrovertierte Schwule.
Ich bin jetzt der Typ ...
... namens Benjamin,
der zufälligerweise
einen Freund hat.
So what?
Ja, genug geredet für heute.
Man muss ja nicht monogam sein.
Ich glaube sowieso nicht, dass
Monogamie wirklich funktioniert.
Bei mir in der Szene,
mit Schwulen, gibt es viele Leute,
die nicht monogam sein wollen,
das finde ich auch voll easy.
Ja.- Es braucht
schon grosses Vertrauen.
Dann gibt es eigentlich
gar kein Problem.- Genau.
Ich fühle mich nicht eifersüchtig,
weil ein Typ, den ich mag,
eine andere Person geil findet.
Das ist das Normalste der Welt,
oder?- Ja, voll.
"Wow, du findest mich nicht die
einzige geile Person auf der Welt?"
What?
Mind blow.
Jetzt hatte ich gerade eine Zeit,
in der ich mich
polyamourös versucht habe.
Ich führte mit mehreren Menschen
eine Beziehung.- Ja.
Ich habe das versucht.
Eine Zeit lang ging es,
es war auch schön.
Aber ich merkte,
mit meinem Rhythmus,
ich studiere ja
mehr als die Hälfte der Woche,
und einen Viertel oder mehr
arbeite ich.
D.h.,
ich bin meist zu 110 % ausgelastet.
Diese paar Tage oder Stunden,
die ich habe,
will ich jeweils
einfach für mich haben.
Vielleicht ins Gym gehen
oder so etwas.
Und deshalb passt
nicht mal ein Freund rein,
geschweige denn zwei oder drei.
* Sanfte Jazz-Musik *
Mega nice!
I love it.
Danke!
- Mega gern.
Mit einem Job
als Betreuer in einer Wohngruppe
für geistig und
körperlich beeinträchtigte Menschen
verdient Beni
derzeit seinen Lebensunterhalt.
Setzt du dich hin, ist gut?
Hoppla, so.
So.
Also.
Einmal hochhalten.
Hoppla, da auch.
Du hast tolle neue Schuhe,
die kenne ich gar nicht.
So.
Dann ...
Heute ist zwar ein warmer Tag,
aber lass die mal an.
So, was machen wir jetzt?
Hu! Okay.
Herein, herein, herein, herein!
Irgendwann kommt sie dann rein. Aha!
Zuerst sagen wir uns
mal Hallo im Spiegel.
Kuckuck!
(Lachend) Genau!
Dann schauen wir uns
ganz nahe im Spiegel an,
um sicher zu sein,
dass wir hier sind.
So.
Und dann ab auf die Toilette.
Mit 15 Jahren ...
Ich hätte das nie gedacht.
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass ich
mal in der Betreuung arbeite.
Ich hätte auch nicht von mir
gedacht, dass ich diese Geduld habe.
Früher war ich
ein sehr ungeduldiger Mensch.
* Sie lacht. *
Ich absolviere ein Studium,
um Lehrer zu werden.
Das nützt mir vielleicht auch
für die Betreuung Beeinträchtigter
in England oder in Spanien.
Ich lerne gerade
Spanisch und Englisch.
Die Welt steht mir offen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Die Träume, die ihr damals hattet,
haben die sich erfüllt?
In der Sek wollte ich irgendwann mal
Schulsozialarbeiterin werden.
Dann dachte ich mir:
"Nein, dafür muss man studieren."
Wenn ich nochmals zurückgehen würde,
und die 14-jährige Meret einen Ein-
blick in mein heutiges Leben hätte,
fände sie das schon cool.
Wo siehst du dich in zehn Jahren?
Ähm ...
Vielleicht in einer WG
mit ein paar Freundinnen.
Ich habe einen Beruf,
ich weiss aber noch nicht welchen.
Und ... ich glaube,
ich bin dann glücklich.
Inzwischen hat Meret eine Lehre
als Fachfrau Gesundheit
im Spital abgeschlossen.
Die Berufsschule
war Deutsch und Englisch
und die Berufsmatura
hat sie auch geschafft.
Nach einem Arbeitseinsatz
bei einem Berufsfischer
studiert sie jetzt
im ersten Jahr Sozialarbeit.
Das WG-Leben teilt sie
mit anderen Studentinnen.
Hoi.
- Hoi! - Hallo.
Es riecht lecker!
Alles im Kühlschrank gehört allen,
ausser es ist angeschrieben.
Ja.
- Das ist eine Regel.
Und ...
Wir haben eine App
und tragen dort alle Ausgaben ein.
Und eine Einkaufslisten-App.
Genau, da schreibt man,
was man einkaufen will.
WG? Wegen des Geldes.
Deshalb wohnen wir in einer WG.
- Schon primär.
Es wäre auch langweilig allein.
- Ja.
Ich habe keine Lust darauf,
dass sonntags niemand daheim ist.
Und mich würde es stressen,
wenn niemand merken würde,
wenn ich nicht nach Hause komme.
Ich finde es schön, wenn ihr merkt,
dass ich nicht heimkomme.
Während der Corona-Zeit
kochten sie oft füreinander
und haben häufig zusammen gelernt.
Heute gab ich den Entwurf
meiner Bachelorarbeit ab.
Wow! - Ja.
- Sehr cool.
Meret ist seit sieben Jahren
mit Arse zusammen.
Er war Schüler
im selben Schulhaus wie sie,
allerdings nicht in derselben Klasse.
Nach einer Lehre als Chemielaborant
absolviert er jetzt
ein Praktikum in einem Jugendtreff.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Wie geht's?
- Gut und dir?
Die beiden haben
schon mal zusammen gewohnt,
leben jetzt aber wieder
getrennt in Wohngemeinschaften.
Als wir wieder ...
- ... auseinanderzogen.
... auseinanderzogen,
da nimmt man sich
bewusster Zeit füreinander.
Das fand ich eigentlich gut.
- Ja.
Darum müsste ich momentan gerade
nicht mit Meret zusammen wohnen,
in der Zukunft
vielleicht dann schon mal.
Mal sehen,
aber im Moment ist es easy so.
Wir haben auch ausprobiert,
was funktioniert.
Oder auch ...
Zum Entscheid, auszuziehen,
trug schon auch das bei,
was nicht funktioniert.
Ich zog nicht aus
und wir trennten uns,
sondern ich zog aus,
weil wir uns nicht trennen wollen.
Ja.
- Wenn das Sinn ergibt.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wir sind hier bei einigen Schülern,
die unsere
allerletzte Party vorbereiten:
die Abschlussfeier
der dritten Sek A.
In den vergangenen drei Jahren,
seid ihr, liebe Schüler/-innen,
die ihr
aus so verschiedenen Ländern kommt,
so verschiedene Sprachen sprecht,
eine eingeschworene Gemeinschaft,
ein Team geworden,
bei dem Klassengeist nicht einfach
eine leere Worthülse ist.
Hört gut zu:
Ihr seid mir oft ein Vorbild.
Eure aussergewöhnliche Leistung,
Ausdauer und Beharrlichkeit
spornen auch mich
immer wieder aufs Neue an.
Ich danke euch für diesen Einsatz
während der letzten drei Jahre
hier an unserer Schule.
Ich danke euch für
die Mitarbeit und die Bereitschaft,
zu lernen,
mitzudenken und mitzureden.
Ich bin sehr stolz,
euer Lehrer gewesen zu sein.
# If all your days are nights ...
Ganz egal,
welchen Weg sie eingeschlagen haben,
sie alle haben sehr viel mehr
von Joe Hediger mitbekommen,
als der Lehrplan vorgesehen hat.
# ... for you.
Ich habe dauernd geheult.
Nicht einmal sehr stark,
sondern sehr oft wenig.
Sehr oft wenig.
- Oh!
Und wieso?
Hat es dich so berührt?
Es wurde mir klar, dass ich die
Meisten vielleicht nie mehr sehe.
Die Schulzeit ist zu Ende,
wir machen keine lustigen Sachen
mehr mit Herrn Hediger.
Was sagen Sie dazu?
Vielen Schülern
wird erst später bewusst,
dass da
ein Lebensabschnitt zu Ende geht.
Darum sagte ich es gestern auch,
es ist wirklich traurig.
Ich hatte zwei tolle Klassen
in den letzten drei Jahren.
Ja, viel mehr
kann ich nicht dazu sagen.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Fröhlicher Popsong: "Go Gentle"
von Robbie Williams *
Dann ...
- Packen wir die Bar aus.- Genau.
# If all your days are nights.
# Days are nights.
# When you want me, I'll be there.
# Say my name,
and I'll be there for you.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
N. Oeggerli, L. Thomann - 2022